[Musique]
1 mais sochaux jazz ces souris guerriers
de la justice sociale sont très souvent
des personnes qui ne comprennent rien au
monde
car ils sont endoctrinés par la
politique progressiste 2
donald trump représente tout ce qui est
mauvais avec la droite en occident le
racisme la xénophobie le capitalisme la
stupidité
qu'est-ce que je viens d'achever avec
ces deux déclarations
quelles émotions via un jeu de provoquer
si vous ne vous sentez pas
personnellement visé par l'un des deux
remarques
vous devez certainement pas recevoir
l'attention qu'elles génèrent et cela
juste avec quelques mots clés quelques
mots clés qui provoque des réactions
spontanées et parfois même scandalisé et
c'est pour ça que je vous propose de se
demander comment et pourquoi je faire
cela et bien tout simplement
j'ai utilisé un langage très chargé et
biase et pour décrire un phénomène
politique
je tends un bref coup d'oeil aux
déclarations donc la première phrase que
j'ai utilisé les seules choses jazz
swing et de la justice sociale sont très
souvent des personnes qui ne comprennent
rien au monde car ils ont endoctrinés
par la politique progressiste premier
mot clef s gender in search of death
warrior ou gears et de la justice
sociale
un terme populaire dans les services
politiques de droite ont payé anglophone
pour décrire les progressistes d'une
manière près j'aurais hâtif jeudi qu'ils
ne comprennent pas le monde et qu'ils
sont endoctrinés premièrement ça
supprime l' agence pour des personnes de
ses convictions politiques mais de plus
ce jeu donnera notre jugement péjoratif
ne comprennent pas le monde tu auras ses
convictions passons à la deuxième phrase
d'aumale chrome représente tout ce qui
est mauvais avec la droite en occident
le racisme la xénophobie le capitalisme
de la stupidité donc clairement
premiers mots clés donald trump tout le
monde connaît de la crème une figure
politique américaine très controversé
jeudi qu'il représente tout ce qui est
faux une généralisation et une
évaluation de validité avec la droite en
occident ensuite je lis tu quatre termes
qui sont clairement très péjoratif au
moins dans ce contexte donc le racisme
la xénophobie le capitalisme la
stupidité
ceux ci sont des évaluations moi je dis
bien sûr que le capitalisme
ce n'est pas nécessairement une mauvaise
chose mais dans le contexte est utilisé
dans une manière péjorative
jusqu'à
que chaque déclaration utilise un
langage chargé que chaque personne aura
très probablement une déclaration qui
leur convient et l'autre quillan dérange
et que ses déclarations provoquent des
fortes réactions mais la question alors
devient pourquoi oui bien sûr c'est ce
langage est chargé mais sûrement pas à
ce niveau je pense que nous pouvons
trouver notre réponse dans la
psychologie humaine quand nous entendons
un mot nous avons tous un sens
particulier associé avec lui par exemple
si je dis le mot pomme nous pensons tous
immédiatement un petit objet rond qui
est rouge ou peut être vert avec une
petite tige que nous pouvons manger
bien sûr ce n'est qu'à un niveau libéral
ensuite nous avons onéreux niveau
supérieur toutes les associations qui
sont d'une nature subjectif donc si
j'aime les pommes ou contextuelle
est-ce que j'ai une pomme chez moi pour
chaque mot nous faisons une combinaison
de ces deux niveaux pour créer nos liens
psychologiques mais ce sont les termes
clés qui sont des vrais mots déclare
japon aussitôt que nous nous entendons
nous faisons des associations en train
de terminer nos perceptions et même
souvent nomura quelqu'un dit donald
trump et tout le monde réagit d'une
manière ou d'une autre
peu importe si la phrase fait un bond
valable non nous sommes tous préparés à
réagir positivement ou négativement
c'est en partie ainsi que notre esprit
fonctionne nous pensons souvent à la
morale au même temps que nous pensons
valeur au contenu mais c'est aussi le
produit du 21e siècle
vous demandez sans doute comment la
situation politique s'était exacerbée au
fil du 21e la réalité c'est que la
situation des siècles passés n'a pas
réellement changé
nous étions toujours polarisé d'une
manière ou d'une autre mais la
différence c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons la nouvelle division des médias
traditionnels des réseaux sociaux des
sites comme youtube
nous sommes constamment connecté de plus
chacune de ces plateformes ont leurs
propres préjugés leur propre opinion sur
la politique mondiale qui est souvent
simplifié ou sensationnaliste pour être
plus attirant pour le public
et quel danger on s'est sentis fication
parce que pour moi c'est d'ici que
vienne au plus grand problème sur le
sujet à cause de ces facteurs nos
perspectives sur d'autres plus en plus
concernés par nos émotions au lieu de la
réalité ce qui nous rend plus polarisé
pour s'assurer que les perspectives du
public ne sont pas brisés par trop de
points de vue contradictoires
chaque côté d'un problème génère une
chambre d'écho
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas le
terme une chambre d'écho et une
situation dans laquelle les mêmes points
de vue sont constamment renforcé dans un
médium compte tenu de ces facteurs les
gens ne comprennent pas notre point de
vue car ils n'entendent presque jamais
d'autres points de vue sauf à travers
des attaques
nous pouvons tous penser à des choses
terribles à dire de l'autre côté
politique et c'est là que nous revenons
au moc et chacune de ces références
négatif à l'autre perspective créer des
liens psychologiques entre les mots clés
la politique et la moralité
autrement dit nous associons
immédiatement certains mots avec
certains perspectives politiques bon ou
mauvais
de plus les médias de ce siècle ne sont
pas locaux toutes les sociétés sur terre
sont maintenant à port connectés nous ne
développons pas simplement comme des
pays séparé comme le faisons autre fois
mais nous grandissons avec nos voisins
proches et lointains il ne fait aucun
doute que cette conférence tedx à perdre
à de nombreux endroits divers et
beaucoup d'entre vous
ont sûrement des amis de différents pays
mais cela signifie aussi que les
conséquences de cette hyper connectivité
ces temps de bien au delà des frontières
de n'importe quel pays nos nombreuses
divisions se propage à vitesse
croissante
cela est particulièrement vrai dans des
sociétés culturellement similaires c'est
particulièrement vrai dans les sociétés
occidentales mais c'est un phénomène
universel arrivons à un des aspect le
plus pernicieux de tout cela la nouvelle
exposition des jeunes aux idées
politiques bien sûr déjà non toujours
été initiés à la politique étant donné
que les opinions de nos parents ont
toujours eu un grand impact sur nous
mais le danger d'aujourd'hui est que les
jeunes sont maintenant exposés à une
politique non filtrée avant même
d'atteindre l'adolescence la raison pour
tout cela est très simple cheminots ils
sont sur les réseaux sociaux où la
politique est pratiquement inévitable
donc non seulement sont ils exposés si
tôt mais comme nous ils sont exposés aux
versions simplifiées et polarisé de la
politique ceux qui manipulent les jeunes
dans des points de vue qui ne
comprennent pas entièrement
donc quelles conséquences ces nouveaux
développements sur nos sociétés nous
devons notre pousse de plus en plus
agressifs les uns envers les autres
un match de plus en plus j'ai la
possibilité d'une société civile c'est
fou devant nos yeux et devient de plus
en plus improbable en exemple
l'autre jour je parlais avec une de mes
meilleures amies et elle a mentionné que
sa soeur avait l'habitude d'être très
autoritaire quand elle était plus petit
je lui ai répondu en disant je connais
ce genre de fille autoritaire de 5 à 8
ans je me souviens qu'elle ait échappé à
tous j'ai utilisé le terme anglais pensé
tout de suite été en colère avec moi
m'accusant de sexisme à cause de mon
utilisation d'utilisation de ce terme
par rapport aux filles je me suis
initialement dit que sa réaction était
complètement extrêmes et je ne
comprenais pas pourquoi elle m'avait
accusé d'être sexiste
puis après 20 minutes j'ai expliqué que
je ne parlais pas de toutes les filles
je ne voulais pas dire que les garçons
n'étaient pas autoritaire je voulais
simplement dire que les enseignants par
exemple avait tendance à laisser un
certain type de fille s'en sortir de
situations difficiles plus facilement
que les garçons elle a cédé le pont et
s'est excusé de m'avoir accusé de
sexisme et je me suis excusé de l'avoir
en français comme vous l'auriez sûrement
reconnu
c'est un autre exemple de mots-clés
provoquant de fortes réactions négatif
je me demande
si je n'étais pas sa meilleure amie
aurait-elle pris le temps de m'écouter
de guérir la fracture rapide que nous
avions créé sûrement la société n'est
pas remplie des gens qui prennent le
temps de s'écouter de régler leurs
problèmes
si cela peut arriver entre deux
meilleurs amis
que sommes-nous censés faire quand ce
sont deux inconnus qui ont de telles
interactions et si cela se produit à un
âge encore plus jeunes comment pouvons
nous changer tout cela
cette fracture deviendra sûrement de
plus en plus large
jusqu'à ce que tout le monde soit séparé
les fractures peuvent bien sûr être très
dangereux pour une société tout comme
des fractures osseuses pour des êtres
humains mais grands points 9 la société
parfois se renforcer à partir d'une
fracture parce qu'elles étaient
nécessaires à sa croissance
un exemple bien évident serait la
séparation de la résistance française du
coup vraiment vichy cela était
nécessaire pour lutter contre les frais
forces du mal
une native mais bien sûr c'est un
événement extrêmement rare
la fracture qui conduit à une guerre
inutile et beaucoup plus courantes dans
la plupart des sociétés par exemple
l'effondrement sociétal observé aux
états unis pendant et après les
élections de 2020 n'est clairement pas
bien pour la société
les deux parties croyais que l'autre
représenter le danger et chercher à
désigner les pires éléments de l'autre
comme leurs éléments fondamentaux
cela a culminé avec les modes du capital
et pourrait facilement s'aggraver dans
un avenir prévisible
bien sûr qu'il y avait d'autres facteurs
que nous n'aborderons pas mais à un
niveau sous jacent l'état des états unis
nous montre yeux
si nous ne pouvons pas accepter que
d'autres personnes puissent avoir des
points de vue très différents que nous
dans une limite résidents
1 et que nos réactions morale à certains
mots et concepts dans son pas
universellement partagée nous ne pouvons
pas avoir une société
eh bien parlons ici de cette société que
je mentionne le thème de cette
conférence
si le changement pour moi de changement
peut être observée sur trois niveaux au
premier niveau le changement
internationale au deuxième niveau le
changement national et sociétales et
ensuite au troisième niveau
le changement individuel bien sûr les
deux premiers niveaux sont extrêmement
importants mais c'est le troisième
niveau qui est le plus important
le changement individuel non réaction
oddo premier niveau
nous avons tous de lagence dans une
certaine mesure nous avons tous deux
choix de la manière dont nous
interagissons avec certains éléments du
média de savoir dans quelle mesure nous
nous impliquons dans la politique et
comment dialoguons avec ceux avec qui
nous sommes en désaccord
les sociétés ne sont pas constitués de
groupe qui est un des régis des uns avec
les autres
ils sont constitués de nous
d'individus qui interagissent les uns
avec les autres
bien entendu des individus forment des
groupes mais ceci implique que c'est
nous qui les gouvernent ont donc ne
pouvons pas laisser la politique devenir
une sud aux religions rival qui détruit
nos réac relation civique tiers de cette
réflexion il ya quelque chose de crucial
l'importance de l'écouté et de la
communication santé coûte la
communication c'est la perte du précieux
lien social une perte que l'on observe
aujourd'hui dans la politique mais aussi
dans notre vie de tous les jours dans
des choses sans le crépuscule du mariage
d'un couple qui ont dérivé
de planèze distante une entreprise qui
manque du succès qu'un personne n'écoute
ses employés un parent qui cherche
désespérément les bons mots pour joindre
son enfant tout est dans nos mots dans
notre écoute notre compréhension des
autres c'est fondamentalement ce qui
nous rend humain la capacité de se
parler de communiquer perdre cela c'est
de perdre la possibilité de se
rassembler de se retrouver le pouvoir de
l' écoute et de l'or battait envers ceux
avec qui nous sommes en désaccord est
une solution simple mais essentielle
pour permettre de retrouver un sentiment
de solidarité commune